[Music]
in general elections this town is a
litmus test for the mood of the nation
the same was true in the referendum
Swindon was part of the revolt against
the EU fifty five percent voted leave
but forget brexit stereotypes this is
neither a declining industrial town nor
a you keep attracting seaside backwater
it has a thriving tech industry Honda is
a major employer
there are numerous small industries and
underneath Swindon's factory rules the
psychological struggle within Britain is
being played out here at Wilson's tools
many workers voted to leave the EU but
the company wanted to stay in around the
55 percent mark probably voted to leave
so yeah
you talk to them about yes we did at the
last minute we sort of got the feeling
that a lot of people were going to vote
for leaves so we started to communicate
a bit more with them as what the effects
would be in here who do you think have
any impact no my guess would be it
didn't change any viewpoints at all
the factory makes tools for the metal
industry because of brexit its had to
reconfigure its business creating a
company in Germany to help transit its
European exports there's quite a lot
cost in computer projects and sort of
changes to infrastructure to allow us to
do this so yeah it's been a very
expensive project so there's a hidden
cost where we'd like to be concentrating
on growing the business we're
concentrating on brexit changes instead
get your act together that would be my
message so Swindon workers defied the
wishes of many of the key employers in
this area and that rift is opening wider
if anything the last two years appears
to have polarized opinion even more with
businesses such as this one more worried
about brexit but the people of Swindon
not so much everyone we spoke to in the
high streets blues cafe bar resolute
about leaving we need to stand around
two feet and let them worry about us you
know let them to do deal with us you
know rather then we need to hobble to
anybody and I stand by our guns and be
strong I can't remember anybody saying
go back to your and do deals over it as
far as I'm concerned leave is lead we
could have made our own rules on
immigration and that do you worry at all
about there being no deal it doesn't
sound like you're worried about that so
what is the big deal about No Deal Honda
is a good example it employs four
thousand people in Swindon and sees a No
Deal brexit as posing serious challenges
to their logistics and their
competitiveness Honda has told Sky News
it should be a priority to avoid no deal
ultimately they want regulatory
alignment with the EU they want access
to the --use international trade
arrangements and they don't want border
checks that could disrupt their supply
chains in other words they want to stay
in the single market and the customs
union smaller firms have similar
problems kun castle exports British
cheese and cream around the world we
have to ensure that this gets into
market before the 29th of March
otherwise after that we don't have an
agreement with Canada so you try to ship
all the stuff out as quickly as possible
absolutely you either gotta get out as
soon as possible or we've actually got
to just take no orders probably from
March
so take the company's cream exports as
an example if we lose Europe's
international trade deals and go on to
World Trade Organization rules Combe
castle will have to pay 25% tariffs on
its exports to Japan 36% to South Korea
and 293 percent tariffs on exports to
Canada we've analysed our options should
we crash out and it would mean that we'd
probably lose about 50% of our business
but in yates pub in Swindon pensioner
Alex Nichol just wants to get on with
brexit well what are you going to say
about the people the 17 million people
like myself who voted for brexit what
are you going to say to them that well
just say that when you cut that one out
you want you can vote again from roses
what I do think well that you do realize
this would be the first referendum in
Great Britain is never been adhered to
why what does was it maybe a girl who
doesn't care instruction then I would
say it to you but like north of England
everybody stop
all them places who were permantly for
brexit yeah Germany clapping I'm just
thinking there'll be an uprising a Sky
News poll shows that views on both sides
have for the most part become more
entrenched and polarized asked have the
last two years made you feel more or
less confident about how you voted 52%
of remainders felt more confident 18%
less so but amongst levers 47 percent
also felt more confident about their
decision with just 20 percent
questioning it one leave voter having
second thoughts is waitress Sophie
Shepard 100 percent yes and as you guys
can see you've looked through and/or
everything shutting the Townsend
business rates are going up foods
getting more expensive to buy it depends
what they'd lay out to me like what
they'd what they've got to offer
No Deal Theresa Mays deal stay in the EU
stay in the EU Swindon still reflects
the mood of the nation dividing confused
frustrated
the legendary Magic Roundabout here in
Swindon is to traffic management what
brexit is to politics
it looks chaotic there are many routes
you can take all in completely different
directions but there's a danger you'll
just keep going round in circles if
you're looking to Swindon for clear
signposting what to do you won't find it
here this town is just as confused as
Westminster Jason Farrell Sky News
you